coronavirus infections are again on the
rise around the world portugal was among
the first european countries hit by a
new summer wave
and while case numbers there are now
starting to fall they are increasing in
countries including the uk and germany
so what can they learn from portugal's
recent wave nicole reese reports from
lisbon
when carlos laitao's voice fills the air
of the club in lisbon
everybody listens
the melancholy sounds of the traditional
portuguese music are once again
attracting big crowds
the pandemic seems far away there's no
social distancing no masks just music
we try to come back to our way of living
and
of course
sometimes we are afraid when we see the
news and something like that news such
as that about the new omicron
sub-variant ba5 it's spreading so
quickly that infection numbers in
portugal recently reached an all-time
high but with less severe illness
still the spike in infections brought
higher covert death rates among the
elderly
now that case numbers are declining
epidemiologists like manuel carmo gomez
are able to evaluate the severity of the
last wave
if you take
the number of cases that there was into
account
then you have lethality which is the
percentage of cases
that die
and lethality has remained very low
after omegro actually it's a level that
is comparable to seasonal flu or even
less caramel gomez says that the new
omicron subvarians very likely evade the
antibodies that people have developed at
least 15 percent of covet cases in
portugal are re-infections due to the
many waves fueled by new variants
this virus does not seem to have a
seasonality similar similar to other
respiratory virus its transmissibility
is so high that even if people start
living outdoors like in the summer it
there will still be transmission he's
hoping for a new generation of vaccines
that not only prevents severe disease
but also suppress transmission in the
meantime it's vital that people remain
alert which is what these tourists are
doing as they enjoy wine tastings and
traveling again
we've waited for two years
to come here we've
i think this trip was cancelled in one
way or another
at least four times
and
when we had the opportunity to come this
summer we decided
it's okay we've been vaccinated we've
been boosted and so we were going to
come regardless and covet is very bad in
washington dc so we've sort of learned
how to maneuver through the
bad parts of it
as have many others here in lisbon too
so is it safe to travel here again in
europe joining us now is christian
lindberger who spokesperson in geneva
what is the takeaway for portugal where
over 90 percent of the population is
vaccinated
well it's a very good example for europe
and for many countries and that's of
course exactly what we would like to to
see everywhere because as we've seen on
the report and as we see it with this
new
variant
or with the new sub lineage
while we don't yet exactly know the
details about the severity of it we see
that while we have many new infections
the death rate is low which is very good
yet we shouldn't be complacent because
we do have a death rate and we have
deaths but if we reach the uh the high
level of vaccination right all over the
world or all over
europe we would be a big big big step
forward um that's the target to reach we
wanted to reach 70 of the world's
population um
uh by by half here this year um we're
not quite there yet we in a general in a
global number we are at 63 percent but
we still have a third of the world's
countries who haven't received any dose
yet um so there's a huge imbalance and
that imbalance we need to settle and we
need to settle make that straight and
once we have a good coverage everywhere
uh from the weakest to the most
vulnerable to everybody then we can be
much
safer looking into the next weeks and
months ahead well historically the
portuguese have always uh been on the
side of getting vaccinated should other
european countries be on alert about
this
we need we need a package it's never
only one thing it's never only the
vaccines and the vaccines are highly
important and we strongly believe that
the low death rates we see right now are
attributable to the fact that a vast
majority of the european population is
vaccinated or actually many in the in
the main traveling countries uh around
the world yet it is important to keep
your masks with you and if you are on a
plane and it's high density if you're in
a group wear your mask because i think
right now at least in my personal
environment and then and the colleagues
and friends i have everybody knows
someone who has just been recently
infected or is sick right now so it is
spreading and it is going around luckily
we haven't seen many severe cases yet
but we have to be in the lookout and be
ready we have to keep testing keep
testing that's important because if we
give up testing then we don't know the
picture it may look
lower than but we don't see the full
picture so everything testing masks
be prepared be vaccinated the whole
package together and then we're much
safer okay so get your booster keep your
mask at hand
and keep on testing you heard it from
christian lindmeier from the world
health organisation thank you